- During my time at university,
I completed quite a few degrees.
I started enrolling myself
in a bachelor of philosophy
with minors in history of
arts, and in economics.
Next, I enrolled myself
in a bachelor of business administration,
both at the University of Munich, LMU.
Actually completed this
one in five semesters,
the bachelor philosophy in
the regular six semesters.
During my bachelor
business administration,
I also spent a semester abroad
at Boccone University in Milan.
Then during the middle of my bachelor,
I enrolled myself in the bachelor of laws,
at the Distance University Hagen,
and the later completed that as well.
At the same time, I enrolled
myself at the CDTM program,
which is a joint institution
of the TU Munich,
the Technical University
Munich, and the LMU, Munich.
And I graduated with an honors degree
in technology management.
I then later enrolled for a
master in accounting and finance
at London School of Economics.
And then of course, in the end,
I also completed my MBA at INSEAD.
So in this video,
I'm going to talk about exactly that,
how did I do that?
How did I study?
Three bachelor degrees in parallel?
And I will also share a couple of tips,
if you intend to do
something similar as well.
And the last will reflect
whether this actually helped
myself in my career or not.
So let's get out and let's get going.
It's a beautiful weekend here in Munich.
Today we're visiting
some of the Munich lakes.
So let me share a couple of considerations
that you have in your mind
when thinking about
starting several bachelors
at the same time.
The first is the selection
of the university.
Here, especially some
private business schools
might not even offer
different degree programs.
At many private business schools,
you can indeed only study business.
The second limitation is that often
also the regulations of university
sometimes do not allow you to be enrolled
in several degree
programs at the same time.
Here in Germany it's especially
the big public universities
that often are little bit more lenient.
I studied at the University of Munich
for my first two bachelor degrees,
and a third at Distance University.
So make sure that the choice of university
supports the study programs
that you want to study.
Second, make sure to combine subjects
that actually compatible with each other,
in regards to the examination
structure that they have.
Here, one advantage of
pairing for instance,
a business degree with liberal arts,
is the business to use usually
are very heavy on exams.
So at the end of the semester,
you will usually have an exam period
where you'll have lots of exams.
And on the other hand, for liberal arts,
there are usually almost no exams at all.
That examination structure looks the way
that you will write lots of essays,
lots of written coursework
that you need to prepare.
And these will often need to
be written during the semester.
So I did the advantage that
at the end of the semester,
I was able to just study
for my business exams,
and didn't need to do that
much work during the semester
for this degree.
And during the semester then,
I indeed had the time to focus
for the philosophy degree,
and make that work.
Third thing strategically
about the semester abroad
that you might do.
So I did a semester abroad at
Bocconi University in Milan
and that actually helped me
to finish my business degree earlier,
because I indeed finished
my bachelor in business
in five semesters,
instead of six semesters,
including the bachelor of theaters.
And one of the main ways I did this
is that in Milan at Bocconi,
I wrote a full exam period
and I was able to carry
over many of the exams
that I wrote in Milan
towards my business degree.
And then once I came back from Milan,
I also completed a full exam period
in the same semester in Munich as well
because there the exams
happen a little bit later
than the exams in Milan
and still had time,
couple of weeks to
prepare for these exams.
So pretty much did the
coursework of two semesters
in only one semester.
And this one enabled me to, for instance
in my last semester complete
an internship at McKinsey.
This enabled me then to fully
focus on my bachelor thesis
in philosophy in semester number six.
Many students actually
extend their studies
if they do a semester abroad.
In my experience if you
set it up the right way,
can actually help you
to complete your studies
in a quicker way.
Let's now talk about time management
because this is a topic I
quite often your questions
on how did you manage to do all this?
How did you manage your time?
In the past already created
a video about this topic.
I will link it somewhere above here.
Let me also know in the comments
if you would like to have
more content on that.
I think the basic insight is
the time management in
these types of situations
isn't even that challenging.
If you just have the
pressure that on this day
you will have the exam.
You will make sure that
the day before the exams
you will do the study.
If there was a coursework,
an essay that you need to submit,
you will make sure that in the days before
you will write this essay
because what would you do instead?
And the truth is most people
would just in the evenings
watch Netflix, hang out
maybe with some friends,
and so on, which of
course can also be fun.
But personally, I found
that I can still do
lots of these things.
I still have lots of fun,
was going out with friends,
but a couple of essay every semester,
a couple of exams in
the end of the semester,
this is still very much possible.
If you just have the
deadline, the pressure,
and not just more or less forced
to put in the time to not fail.
So was all the effort really worth it?
And let's look at that
from three perspectives.
First to get my very first job,
in consulting at McKinsey.
Second, for my mid to long
term career development.
And third, just for my very personal life.
First for McKinsey, did this
help me to get into McKinsey?
And very frankly I'd
say yes, it did help me.
I think it was something a
little bit special that I did
to study both business philosophy, law.
Surely not all the other
business candidates did that.
I think especially when
you study business,
it's important to have a special spike,
something special that other people
are not necessarily doing.
And for me, I'd say that
was one of the factors,
of course do not know how my
profile would've been assessed
if I wouldn't have done that,
but for sure that did not hurt me.
Second, how did this help me with my roles
after McKinsey.
And if frank, I didn't
think it had that much
of an effort more or
less all the things I did
after McKinsey were very much based
on my network, personal
relationships that I had
up to this job.
Frankly I'm not sure if I will ever apply
to any job again in the future,
rather just classically
with a CV and a cold way
apply somewhere.
And I think that's probably choice
independent from your degree.
I think the further you
advance in your career,
the less important your
actually degrees will be
that you may be accomplished/attained
somewhere in the past.
I think at some point it's just
not that important anymore.
I think it especially helps you to get
into get that very first job.
And third, how to assess this for myself,
for my personal development,
for the knowledge that I built.
and here frankly starting
with the business degree
spanning a couple of years
in management consulting
would at least as effective
at starting completing
a bachelor in business.
So that's why it helped me of course,
to get the context
understanding a couple of things
a bit better.
Just for that probably the
time in consulting alone
would've done at least
that much for me myself.
Second, the philosophy degree,
I think this very much shaped
just how I approach problems,
how I think about problems.
I think it's just very
difficult also for myself
to see how I would approach things.
So I would see things
if I wouldn't have studied that degree.
Surely it helped me a lot to
develop my critical thinking.
It's very difficult for me to assess
how this would've looked like
if I wouldn't have done that.
And thirdly law degree,
this might be actually the degree
where I got the most practical value from,
especially in my roles
after con consulting,
because directly after McKenzie,
I moved into a mid-size German retailer
in a restructuring role as a CTO.
And I was faced with
lots of legal questions
in this position.
I did work together with
many lawyers at the time.
Here this legal basic understanding
was insanely important helpful to me.
And even now in my current role
in startup in the management
position in startup.
I'm also facing legal
questions almost all the time.
And it's really important, helpful for me
to have this background.
Of course, I'm not as
qualified as a lawyer,
but at least I know what
they're talking about.
I can assess whether what someone tells me
makes sense or not.
And this is immensely helpful indeed.
So if you study several degree
programs in parallel as well,
let me know about your
experiences in the comments.
I do hope this may be inspired some of you
to do similar things
in the future as well.
If you took away any value
out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe and turn
on the notification bell
to stay up to date with the content.
Big, big thanks to all
the members of the channel
for your help.
This is very much appreciated.
My name is Heinrich.
I read content every single
Saturday here on the video.
So all the best to you,
see you next week.
and bye bye.